Tosh and I don't know each other really
we have the same manager always liked
each other I remember the last time I
saw him I remember introducing him at
The Comedy Store being like we're not
friends but we respect each other and
brought him on stage and he thought that
was really funny like we get along we
just we haven't been in the same room
very often I like him a lot I think he's
a very smart guy I like the way he's
approached his career you're saying
comeback I don't believe it's a comeback
this did 10 years of Tosh.0
where they were doing a they made a
million episodes of that thing
that's just what he was doing and he was
touring constantly while that was
happening was all part of a big deal he
made so much money that when it
was over he took some time to chill it
was also a global pandemic so I don't
think this is a comeback he just like
took a little time believe he had a kid
I'm not exactly sure but I believe he
had a kid and then he's like I left to a
comeback he's doing a thing with Amazon
he's doing this podcast I guess he just
wants to work he just wants to be busy I
mean he he could never work again and be
fine I think he's just doing whatever he
wants to do and figuring it out but I
wouldn't call it a comeback people are
like why is he hosting this Amazon
reality show because he's getting so
much money that you would slit the
throat of everyone you've ever kissed to
have just 10% of it so that's why